hi everyone this is kevin from the chess
website comm and today we're going to be
looking at the fogger counter gambit and
someone can correct me if I'm wrong but
I think this is going to be the first
youtube analysis video on the fogg
birkenau gaming so I think it's going to
be pretty good I've been playing this
defense exclusively for the past week
trying to get more insight into it so I
think this video is going to be very
informative for everyone that watches it
the fiber counter game it starts with
white to e4 black responding pawn to e5
and white go going into the Kings gambit
line now I can tell you being a Kings
gambit player myself I really hate
seeing the fogger counter gambit anytime
a player plays the King's game but they
really want to be the aggressor in the
game they really want to attack early
and often and the [ __ ] counter gambit
which is pawn to d5 pretty much takes
away all the main lines that White's
used applying in the Kings gambit line
and it really gets them out of their
comfort zone and today we're going to be
looking at all the different moves that
White has that you may see we're going
to look at the main line and we're going
to look at how to exploit any mistakes
that you may see and if you are white
how to respond correctly and what bow
shot what both sides should be thinking
when they see this now White has a lot
of places that he can hang himself and
so I want to go over those to make sure
that if you do see them you can take
advantage right away the first one the
most obvious is if pawn captures to e5 a
lot of times white just gets flustered
they're not really sure which pawn to
capture the captures pawn e5
we can simply bring our Queen to h4 just
a devastating move if he tries to block
with his pawn here we can simply take on
e4 and we're forking this rook check in
the King here
if he decides to move his King and said
we can just simply bring our queen
capture on e4 his only move is King to
f2 we can simply bring our Bishop to c5
check he can either move his king or he
can try something like pawn to d4 we can
just recapture because our Queens
protecting so if he wants to give us
this Queen either way blacks going to
win this game fairly easy so that's
obviously going to be a very bad move as
we can see
another move you'll see often is simply
Knight to c3 now from here we're simply
going to take pawn to f4 now White has
two options here to take this pawn on d5
and you want to make sure that if they
take it with the wrong piece that you
make them pay most people like to
capture with their pawn they don't like
to extend their minor pieces too far out
in the game well this is actually going
to be a mistake for what if he does that
meaning that if he captures with his
pawn on d5 thinking that his knights
protecting we can actually bring our
Queen to h4 again check the King again
White has two options he can move his
King into the middle which completely
out of safety or he can simply bring his
pawn to d3 and we can to retake with no
no room for white to recapture because
and we can simply just take his rook on
h1 so that's going to be the wrong way
but it's going to be the more tempting
way for white to recapture now if white
does capture with his knight which you
should black and simply come to f6 with
his Knight and then white is going to
take on f4 now we can come in and
develop our knight to c6 we eventually
want to take on this pawn on e4 but
right away
again it is a counter gambit so we are
giving up a pawn at the very beginning
we're trying to get a spatial advantage
and center control faster than white by
giving up that extra pawn at the
beginning so I like to have both in the
piper counter game at both the Knights
out right away and then depending on
where he goes you can develop and attack
from there so make sure that if he
doesn't defend correctly that you make
them pay
now another defense that you'll see
quite often is simply Knight to f3
obviously this is the most common line
in the Kings gambit line so if a player
really doesn't know what to do they may
simply just continue with their line and
not really pay much attention to it
from here we can simply just capture on
f4 and then why really has to decide how
he wants to defend here if he captures
with pawn to d5 we can simply develop
our Knight to f6 attacking this this
pawn on d5 and whites has two options
obviously he wants to defend this he can
defend it one with Knight to c3 but from
here we can simply take freely as you
can see if he takes them we can retake
with her with our queen obviously if he
tries to bring his bishop into the act
we can do the same thing we can capture
and if he captures we can recapture we
have great center control here or you
may see him bring his pawn to c4 now if
you see this this is just a really bad
move because he's basically already
weakened his King side and now he's
weakening his Queen side even more from
here we can simply bring our pawn to c6
attacking this piece trying to basically
mix this up if he does recapture then we
can simply recapture with our knight on
c6 developing and bringing it to a very
good square and you can see from here
black has a pretty good setup we can
bring our bishop into the action we can
Castle kingside
white is completely flustered as King
side is weak his Queen side is weak
blacks gonna have a really good game
here and that's kind of what you're
looking for in the fall career counter
game
it may not be the most technically sound
but it gives you a lot of fighting
options and it plays really well
especially getting someone that's not
used to playing against it so that is
one of the more common things that
you'll see another thing you may see is
they may just challenge with pawn to d3
obviously this is going to be a huge
mistake because we can take and then
when they recapture then we can simply
take their queen on d1 and when they
retake with their king we're going to be
in great position they're kinking a
longer castle obviously we can just
recapture this pawn here we're going to
be even in material but at the same time
we're going to have a much better game
because their King is in the center and
he can't castle and we can still develop
our pieces freely so if you see d3 right
away that's going to be a mistake for
them we'll go ahead and get into the
main line though and that is simply pawn
captures d5 and from here and again if
you're white and you see this this is
going to be your best move just go ahead
and take the the pawn that they are
offering you and move forward with the
game from here pawn blacks actually
going to just push forward with pawn to
e4 and this is actually a really
powerful move by black so white really
wants to remove this pawn on e4 and you
may see two ways the most common is
simply just d3 but you may see
Knight to c3 it doesn't matter which one
if you're black you're going to respond
the same way and that's Knight to f6
putting a defender on this e4 pawn now
if they continue the point and bring a
pawn to d3
well now you can actually develop even
more pieces and you're going to be
pinning the knight down to the King here
now let's say he captures with his pawn
black is going to recapture you can
already see the tension that's building
we're attacking this piece and at the
same time where we're pinning it down to
the King why it's really going to have a
weak Queen side attack once we're done
with him but let's say he doesn't bring
out his knight let's say his first move
is simply just pawn to d3 from here
we're just going to bring our knight
into the action with Knight to f6 and
the most common move and the mainline is
simply white recaptures on e4 and then
blacks going to capture on e4 with this
Knight and this is the setup that you're
going to see more times than not and
this is the part that I really want to
look at White's really got a pretty bad
setup as far as center control and King
side safety he really doesn't have any
of that so this is as you can see we're
down upon we have two pawns down and
they're down one so we are down upon but
we have pretty good control and from
here white can still make a lot of
mistakes obviously anytime you're up in
material you want to trade down you may
see a common mistake of let's say Knight
to c3 attacking this Knight basically
trying to remove it since it isn't a
good square white can't attack it with
any pond so we can just kind of hang out
there we can even bring our Bishop to f5
and put another defender on that the
Knights not going anywhere for a while
so why it may tries to get rid of it
from here that we have a pretty awesome
move as y'all seen before the Queen just
eyes on this h4 spot and it's a pretty
devastating move obviously the King can
or they can bring the pawn to g3 he
moves his king out his Kings going to be
even more unsafe than he was before if
he does move his pawn out then we can
simply take our knight get them away
from danger from the knight on c3 and we
can just capture if white here
recaptures we're going to get a free
rook out of it so even from this
position which you'll see a lot in the
mainline if someone has studied it
you're still going to have a lot of
fighting options in white against the
fogger counter game it has many many
ways to hang himself
so this is a popular counter gambit if
you haven't already played and I highly
recommend it it's fun if you'd like to
attack and like very very fast-paced
games especially is black and you do
come across the King's gambit I highly
recommend this so I hope you guys
learned as much from this video as I
have if you haven't already please
subscribe I've got some other cool
videos coming out in the future and I'll
see you guys next video thanks for
watching